nos piden que factor hicimos esta
expresión que tengo aquí 4 cuadrada 4
menos 15 lo primero que quiero que te
des cuenta que tenemos un 4 al lado de
la ye cuadrada y además el menos 15 no
es divisible entre 4 por lo tanto no
podemos factorizar de esta expresión un
4 y eso quiere decir que no hay forma de
quitar este 4 al lado de la ye cuadrada
por lo tanto se me ocurre factorizar
esto por agrupación y recuerda que
cuando pensábamos en factorizar esto por
agrupación nos fijamos en el producto de
dos números tales que el producto de
estos dos números sea 4 x menos 15 que
por cierto esto vale menos 60 y la suma
de estos dos números me tienen que dar
este de aquí en medio a más b tiene que
ser igual a 4 y bueno esto ya lo hemos
visto en varios vídeos necesitamos dos
números que su multiplicación mete menos
60 y bueno si te das cuenta dos números
multiplicados que me den menos 60 es más
dos números que multiplicados me den
algo negativo tiene que ser uno positivo
y uno negativo entonces tiene que ser
positivo y entonces me tiene que ser
negativo
al revés y por otro lado la suma de
ambos tiene que ser igual a 4 esto
quiere decir que la resta de ambos tiene
que ser igual a 4 o dicho de otra manera
que la diferencia de sus valores
absolutos tiene que ser igual a 4 fíjate
vamos a poner los números aquí que no
tienen nada que ver con estos dos
números al azar me voy a tomar
supongamos tres y dos menos dos por tres
esto me da menos seis date cuenta que
uno positivo y uno negativo me dan de
resultado algo negativo que es algo como
lo que queremos aquí y su suma meta uno
menos dos más tres me da uno positivo y
si te das cuenta lo que hice fue sumar
dos pero al sumar dos me tomé realmente
una diferencia la diferencia de los
valores absolutos tres menos dos es lo
mismo que 1 es decir me tomen la
diferencia de sus valores absolutos y es
justo a esto a lo que me refiero aquí
voy a buscar dos números tales que
multiplicados media menos 60 y que la
diferencia de sus valores absolutos me
den 4 así que para esto pues voy a
agarrar y tomarme a todos los factores
de 60 y déjenme escribirlos por aquí
todos los factores de 60 quiénes son
en quien podemos descomponer al 60 al 60
lo podemos descomponer en 1 y 60 160 62
y 30 y es más déjenme borrarlo todo el
mejor no voy a poner como columna 1 y 62
y 33 y 320 320
después me queda 4 y 15 5 y 12 también 5
y 12 y por último 6 y 10 y bueno ya sé
que aquí se nota claramente que 6 y 10
es la respuesta sin embargo vamos a
intentar aprobar con alguno de todos
estos para que veas que solamente la
única respuesta es 6 y 10 y además que
lo que queremos es justo estos dos
números estos dos valores que tengo aquí
porque fíjate si nosotros pensamos en
los dos primeros valores que tenemos
aquí 1 y 60 si yo me tomo la diferencia
de todos es más supongamos que uno es
positivo y 60 negativo me darían de
resultado pues menos 59 menos 59
entonces fíjate bien que la diferencia o
la distancia entre estos dos números
siempre va a ser 59 y es que el 1 puede
ser positivo o negativo de 60 a tener
que ser entonces
activo positivo recuerda que los signos
tienen que ser contrarios cuando me tomo
el positivo este es negativo cuando me
tomo el negativo este tiene que ser
positivo y si fuera al revés es negativo
y positivo me daría el resultado más 59
menos uno más 60 es más 59 pasa lo mismo
con 2 y 30 como puedo variar los signos
positivos negativos el resultado no va a
quedar menos más 28 o más menos 28 según
como tenemos los signos porque al final
la distancia que hay entre 12 y 30 es 28
sin embargo puedo hacer lo mismo con
todos estos pero te das cuenta que la
solución ya la tenemos aquí la solución
tiene que ser 6 y 10 porque 6 por 10 me
dan 60 y fíjate que si 10 es positivo y
el 6 es negativo entonces cuando yo sumo
estos dos me dan de respuesta 4 positivo
y que es justo lo que queremos por lo
tanto ya puedo yo romper esta expresión
que tengo aquí y empezar a escribir la
de una manera distinta 4 y lo voy a
escribir como menos 6 + 10 james
entonces déjame ponerlo aquí 4 james es
lo mismo que menos 6
+ 10 porque date cuenta que es justo lo
que queríamos
- 6 yemas 10 bien me dan más 4 james y
por otra parte tengo aquí 4 y cuadrada y
menos 15 y bueno vamos a factorizar por
agrupación y como era esto me tomo los
dos primeros términos y de aquí voy a
factorizar todo lo que se pueda lo más
posible no voy a tomar también los otros
dos términos y de aquí también voy a
factorizar todo lo que se pueda así que
cuatro y cuadrada menos seis pues estos
dos tienen en común 1 2
entonces dossiers lo más que podemos
sacar de aquí y me queda 4 y cuadrada
entre 22 y menos 6 james entre 2 y me da
menos 3 muy bien ya tengo el primer
paréntesis factor izado ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo con el segundo paréntesis
tengo 10 menos 15 lo más que puedo
factorizar es un 5
me queda 5 que multiplica a 2 10 menos 3
y que crees
2 - 3 es ahora nuestro factor común por
lo tanto lo podemos sacar de esta
expresión y me queda 210 menos 3 que a
su vez multiplica a los otros dos aquí
bueno por una parte multiplicador james
y por otra parte multiplica a 5 y ya con
esto
encontré la factorización por agrupación
de esta expresión realmente no estaba
tan difícil